>>> GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SELL ACCESS TO THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT,
EVENING SITTING VICE PRESIDENTS
LIKE JOE BIDEN ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO THAT.
IT'S A CRIME.
IT'S ALSO A CRIME FOR ANYONE IN
THE UNITED STATES TO COMMIT
FRAUD, TO DEFRAUD THEIR BUSINESS
PARTNERS.
IN THE PORTION OF THE INTERVIEW
THAT YOU JUST SAW TONY
BOBULINSKI PRESENTED EVIDENCE,
WHICH WE EXAMINED, THAT HUNTER
BIDEN DID THIS.
HE COMMITTED FRAUD AGAINST TONY
BOBULINSKI AND HIS OTHER
BUSINESS PARTNERS.
THE BIDEN FAMILY DID THAT.
BOBULINSKI GAVE THAT EVIDENCE TO
THE FBI.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
WE ASKED TONY BOBULINSKI.
>> SINCE YOU ARE AT THE VERY
CENTER OF THE STORY SINCE YOU
WERE THE CEO OF SINOHAWK
HOLDINGS.
>> I WISH I WASN'T.
>> I KNOW.
I WILL ASK YOU ABOUT THAT IN A
MINUTE BECAUSE IT'S A SAD STORY.
SINCE YOU ARE AS A FACTUAL
MATTER AT THE VERY CENTER OF
THIS STORY, TELL US ABOUT YOUR
PERSONAL INTERACTIONS WITH THE
FBI.
>> WELL DOCUMENTED.
I WENT TO THE SECOND DEBATE IN
NASHVILLE BETWEEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND JOE BIDEN.
>> MY SON HAS NOT MADE MONEY IN
TERMS OF THIS THING ABOUT WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT IN CHINA?
I HAVE NOT HAD-THE ONLY GUY THAT
MADE MONEY FROM CHINA IS THIS
GUY.
HE'S THE ONLY ONE.
NOBODY ELSE HAS MADE MONEY FROM
CHINA.
>> THAT NIGHT I FLEW TO DC AND
THERE WAS A BIG DEBATE.
WHAT I VOLUNTARILY WALK INTO THE
FBI OR DO I SIT DOWN WITH
SENATORS JOHNSON AND SENATOR
GRASSLEY?
MY LAWYERS DECIDED IT WAS BETTER
THAT I VOLUNTARILY GO IN TO SIT
AND PROVIDE THESE FACTS.
ON THE MORNING OF OCTOBER 23RD,
THE MORNING AFTER THE DEBATE, I
SPENT FIVE PLUS HOURS SITTING IN
A ROOM WITH AS MUCH AS SIX
FEDERAL AGENTS WALKING THROUGH
ALL THE FACTS OF MY KNOWLEDGE OF
THE BIDEN FAMILY, HOW I GOT
INVOLVED IN THIS, THE TRIPS
AROUND THE WORLD, CFC, CHAIRMAN
YI AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
AT THE END OF THAT MEETING, AND
REMEMBER I VOLUNTARILY WENT
THERE, SO THEY WERE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY INFORMATION I PROVIDED
TO THEM.
I WISH I HAD PICTURES OF THE
FACES OF THE TWO MAIN AGENTS
THAT WERE INTERVIEWING ME.
I WOULD SAY SOMETHING AND YOU
COULD JUST SEE THE SHOCK IN
THEIR FACE AND THEY WOULD SAY
LET'S TAKE A MINUTE.
THEY WOULD GET UP AND WALK OUT
OF THE ROOM.
THE AGENTS WOULD CONVENE AND
THEN COME BACK AND RESTART THE
INTERVIEW.
THESE FACTS FOR THE SAKE OF OUR
COUNTRY AND NATIONAL SECURITY.
AT THAT POINT HE WAS CANDIDATE
JOE BIDEN AND NOW HE'S THE
SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, THE MOST POWERFUL PERSON
IN THE FREE WORLD.
DAUNTING.
AT THE END OF THAT FIVE PLUS
HOUR INTERVIEW THE HEAD OF
STATION TOLD MY LAWYERS, LISTEN,
AN INDIVIDUAL NAMED TIM TEBOW
WILL RUN POINTS ON ALL OF THIS.
WE DEFINITELY WILL HAVE TONY
COME IN FOR A FOLLOW-UP
INTERVIEW.
IT COULD BE AS EARLY AS NEXT
WEEK.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
WEREN'T WELL VERSED ON THESE
FACTS.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE
COME IN FROM BALTIMORE OR
DELAWARE.
I WAS READY TO SIT DOWN WITH
ANYBODY THAT NEEDED ME TO OR
TRAVEL WHEREVER I WANTED TO.
THEY HAD TO GIVE MY LAWYERS TIM
TEBOW'S CELL PHONE NUMBER.
TIM WAS NOT THERE THAT DAY.
HE WAS OUT OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
MY LAWYERS HAD AN OUR CALL WITH
HIM THAT FRIDAY NIGHT ON OCTOBER
23RD.
SUBSEQUENT CALLS THROUGH THE
WEEKEND AND THE FOLLOWING WEEK
WHEN I WAS THEN COMING ON YOUR
SHOW TO PROVIDE THE FACTS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING
OF FOLLOW-UP INTERVIEW.
TIM TEBOW WITH MY LEGAL COUNSEL
SAID WE KNOW TONY IS
COOPERATING.
WE APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION HE
HAS PROVIDED.
WE WILL FOLLOW-UP WITH YOU.
WE WILL HAVE HIM COME UP FOR A
FOLLOW-UP INTERVIEW AND SPEND
MORE TIME ON THIS.
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THEM SINCE.
>> IS THAT ALL?
>> NO.
NOR HAVE MY LAWYERS.
>> NO COMMUNICATION WHATSOEVER
SINCE BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTION?
>> CORRECT.
>> THAT IS SHOCKING.
>> SHOCKING, YEAH, THAT IS ONE
ADJECTIVE.
>> TELL US ABOUT TIM TEBOW.
>> I DIDN'T INTERACT WITH HIM.
MY LAWYERS DID.
WE HAD EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS.
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION IS VERY
SENSITIVE AND HOW IT'S BEING
HANDLED.
THE IMAGES OFF MY CELL PHONES,
DETAILED CHAT DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE CHINESE, WIRES.
THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION HERE
IS STAGGERING.
>> THE FBI TOOK POSSESSION OF
THAT INFORMATION?
>> THEY DID.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT WENT.
TO YOUR POINT EARLIER OF ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I AM SITTING
HERE, DURING THE SUMMER THERE
HAS BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHISTLEBLOWERS COMING FORWARD.
COMING FORWARD TO SENATOR
GRASSLEY, SENATOR JOHNSON,
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, CONGRESSMAN.
THEY ARE COMING OUT OF THE
WOODWORK.
I THINK IT WILL CONTINUE TO
ACCELERATE.
APPARENTLY A VARIETY OF
WHISTLEBLOWERS CLAIM THAT TIM
TEBOW WAS SUPPRESSING FACTS.
IMAGINE I AM IN EUROPE TRAVELING
AND I'M STARTING TO SEE-I CALL
MY LAWYERS MONTHLY.
BY EVAN I'VE BEEN CALLED IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY?
THIS MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD FOLLOW-UP
WITHIN A WEEK AND DO FOLLOW-UP
INTERVIEWS.
MY LAWYERS ARE LETTING THE
PROCESS WORK THROUGH.
WE HAVE RESPECT FOR THE COUNTRY.
I WAS TRYING TO RESPECT THE
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU HEAR THE
PERSON THAT YOU ARE TOLD WAS
ASSIGNED TO RUN POINTS ON
THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS AND TEXT
MESSAGES AND CALENDARS AND
TRAVEL ARRANGEMENTS AND ALL
THAT, THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL JUST
WALKED OUT OF THE FBI
HEADQUARTERS IN DC.
HE'S GOT TO START ASKING
QUESTIONS.
>> THE ALLEGATIONS THAT HE IS A
PARTISAN ACTOR ACTING ON BEHALF
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
THAT'S THE ALLEGATION?
>> MULTIPLE WHISTLEBLOWERS HAVE
COME FORWARD AND CLAIMED THAT.
CORRECT.
>> WOULD YOU SPEAK TO THE FBI
AGAIN?
>> I WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
AT ANY TIME.
NOT JUST THE FBI, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY ATTORNEY.
THESE FACTS ARE EXTENSIVE, WELL
DOCUMENTED, EASILY VERIFIED
METADATA.
MULTIPLE SOURCES SAY THE SAME
THING.
ZERO CHANCE THAT THIS HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA OR
DISINFORMATION.
>> WE HAVE REAPED PURRED
REPEATEDLY ACCOUNTS THAT THERE
IS OR WAS A GRAND JURY IMPANELED
IN DELAWARE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> I KNOW ONE THING.
I HAVEN'T BEEN CALLED IN FRONT
OF THEM.
THAT IS SURPRISING,
DISAPPOINTING.
>> YOU ARE THE BUSINESS PARTNER.
>> SOME PEOPLE SAY AREN'T YOU
HAPPY YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO SIT IN
FRONT OF PEOPLE FOR 20 HOURS AND
BEING ASKED A THOUSAND
QUESTIONS?
I SAY OUR COUNTRY DESERVES THE
FACTS.
THEY NEED TO KNOW THE FACTS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A MEDIA AND SOME
OF THE BIGGEST TECH COMPANIES
LIKE FACEBOOK, TWITTER PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THEY DID
SUPPRESS THE STORY.
JACK DORSEY OF TWITTER PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGING IT WAS A MISTAKE.
>> WE MADE A TOTAL MISTAKE WITH
THE NEW YORK TIMES POST.
WE CORRECTED THAT WITHIN 20 FOR
HOURS.
IT DIDN'T HAVE TO DO WITH THE
CONTENT.
IT WAS A HACK TO MATERIALS
POLICY.
WE CHANGE THAT BASED ON NOT
WANTING TO DELETE THAT.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH IT.
I SEE IT.
IT IS SOMETHING WE LEARNED.
>> IT WASN'T A DO OVER.
WE DIDN'T GET TO GO BACK AND FIX
THE HISTORY THAT WAS ALTERED.
THIS IS HISTORY ALTERING FACTS.
DEBATE WITH ANYBODY.
PUT ME IN A ROOM WITH ANYBODY
THAT CLAIMS ANYTHING I'VE SAID,
ANY DOCUMENT I HAVE PRODUCED IS
ALTERED OR FABRICATED.
I WOULD LOVE THAT CHALLENGE.
>> FBI DIRECTOR CHRIS RAY
DISPATCHED HIS AGENTS ON THE
LARGEST MANHUNT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY TO APPREHEND AND
INCARCERATE HUNDREDS OF
MIDDLE-AGE PEOPLE WITH NO
CRIMINAL RECORDS FOR TRESPASSING
IN THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
WHEN THE CAPITOL POLICE LIFTED
THE GUARDS AND LET THEM IN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SPENDING THEIR TIME DOING.
BUT NOT ONE FBI AGENT COULD CALL
TONY BOBULINSKI BACK WHO
PRESENTED THEM HARD DOCUMENT